bienvenue à tous vous êtes sur LCP
Public Sénat c'est l'heure de Parlement
Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actu parlementaire et politique avec
Michael zaves
du tumulte cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle avec la loi Macron qui
divise à droite comme à gauche 200
articles divers et variés 3000
amendements un examen au patchage parmi
les mesures les plus controversées
l'extension du travail dominical et la
libéralisation des professions
réglementées coup de chaud entre le
président de l'Assemblée nationale et
celui du Sénat Claude barthelen Prome
une nouvelle fois la suppression du
Sénat Gérard lâcher refuse désormais de
travailler avec son homologue du Palais
Bourbon le torchon brûle et puis la
lutte contre le jihad face aussi par
Internet de commissions à l'Assemblée au
Sénat réfléchissent au moyen qu'elles
ont de contrer les réseaux de
recrutement de son côté le gouvernement
adéquoy le style le site stop djihadiste
pour lutter contre la propagande sur le
net et on va développer toute cette
actualité avec notre invité barbara
Pompili bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
de la comme cours président du groupe
EELV Europe Écologie Les Verts
vous avez déclaré cette semaine vous me
dites si je me trouve que vous ne
souhaiteriez retourner au gouvernement
si vous ne retournez pas au gouvernement
ce serait pour vous un échec c'est une
offre de service c'est pas une question
d'offre de service la question est de
savoir comment on fait dans la situation
actuelle qui est une situation difficile
de crise économique et de crise sociale
comment on fait pour atteindre 2017 avec
une meilleure situation moi j'entends
beaucoup de gens qui s'excitent sur les
élections présidentielles de 2017 pour
moi le sujet n'est pas là aujourd'hui le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est comment on
réussit à relever ce pays
pour pour relever ce pays la solution à
tout n'est pas de rentrer au
gouvernement c'est pas la question mais
c'est est-ce que on peut avoir une unité
plus large de la majorité est-ce que la
majorité entière peut être associée à ce
assez réformes aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
à suffisamment le cas en tout cas et
même même quand Julien Bayou le
secrétaire le jeune secrétaire de LV
elle dit qu'il faut de retour de graisse
il dit il faut une primaire à la gauche
de la gauche c'était responsable dit
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis vous dites
quoi je dis que Julien Bayou là exprimé
une opinion personnelle c'est dommage
qu'il est marqué porte-parole par des
d'Europe écologique parce qu'il me
semble oui mais il me semble que Europe
Écologie Les Verts on a pris aucune
position en ce sens et encore une fois
je pense que là il y a un problème de
timing la question n'est pas de quelle
est la primaire de 2017 la question
c'est aujourd'hui comment on travaille
pour relever l'économie de ce pays et
puis ce pays socialement et la société
française d'ici 2017 il y a deux ans on
va pas passer deux ans à parler de la
présidentielle on a deux ans pour
travailler donc c'était responsable de
dire ça je sais surtout un très mauvais
timing on va y revenir vous inquiétez
pas mais on va passer un petit peu sur
le reste de l'actualité et évidemment
lundi on se réveille avec la Grèce qui
balcule vers la gauche en France
certains se prennent à rêver
la victoire d'alexispra sans Grèce pour
la première fois un parti de gauche
radical arrive au pouvoir en Europe
cette élection a raviver les espoirs
notamment de l'ultra gauche en France on
voit ça tout de suite en images
réaction presque unanime de la classe
politique française pour saluer la
victoire de Syriza en Grèce son leader
Alexis tsipras a été félicité par
François Hollande dans un communiqué de
l'Elysée le président de la République
fait part de sa volonté de poursuivre
les trois de coopération entre nos deux
pays au service de la croissance et de
la stabilité le gouvernement en profite
également pour réaffirmer son soutien à
la ligne politique du vainqueur ces
peuples disent qu'ils attendent une
politique différente et c'est cette
politique François Hollande en
particulier a essayé de défendre en
Europe des évolutions déjà eu lieu on a
vu ce qui se passe sur la Banque
centrale européenne mais c'est bien dans
les rangs de l'extrême gauche que l'on
exulte du NPA au parti communiste en
passant par le Parti de Gauche c'est une
journée historique parce que
la période que nous avons connue de la
toute-puissante arrogante des libéraux
de leur presse soi-disant recette
miracle pour sauver les économies c'est
fracassé en Grèce pour la première fois
c'est un changement radical qui est
voulu par le peuple mais d'une manière
démocratique pacifique avec des
bulletins de vote même euphorie à
l'extrême droite Marine Le Pen avait
souhaité la victoire de cyriza je me
réjouis de la gifle démocratique
monstrueuse que le peuple grec vient
d'administrer à l'Union européenne si en
2011 on s'était attaché à savoir ce que
le peuple grec pensait et bien
probablement la Grèce ne serait pas dans
la situation d'aujourd'hui à l'UMP
beaucoup appellent à respecter le choix
des Grecs certains espèrent un virage
dans la politique européenne seul l'UDI
Hervé Morin est incisif sur Twitter les
Grecs ont oublié que c'est grâce à
l'Europe qu'ils n'ont pas été en
faillite
la Grèce n'est pas la France qu'on peut
pas faire forcément d'extrapolation mais
quand on voit la réaction de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il se prend pour ses bras
il faut
vivre à raison active ce qui s'est passé
en Grèce c'est très intéressant et je
crois effectivement qu'il faut qu'on
regarde ce qui s'y passe pour en tirer
des leçons la politique austéritaire
très forte qu'a vécu la Grèce qui n'a
rien à voir avec celle dont on parle ici
en France c'est une politique qui n'a
pas eu de bons résultats aujourd'hui la
dette est toujours très très forte elle
sait même envolée malgré les politiques
qui ont été faites et puis l'économie du
pays est exemple donc qu'il fasse qu'il
faille revoir la politique du pays et
notamment justement sur les efforts qui
sont demandés
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est quoi en fait
leur but là
ce sont ce sont tous les deux on n'ont
que très peu de points communs mais ils
ont une défiance vis-à-vis de l'Europe
là justement c'est à l'Europe de montrer
qu'elle est capable au-delà juste de
donner des sanctions qu'elle est capable
d'être rassembleuse et de justement
d'aider la Grèce à s'en sortir alors il
y a eu des il y a eu des aides qui ont
été donnés à la Grèce l'Europe a donné
des centaines de milliards d'euros voilà
des centaines de milliards et d'autres
mais ce qui était imposé n'était
peut-être pas la bonne solution
aujourd'hui il faut réinvestir dans
l'économie de ce pays les efforts il
faut pas toujours les demander au même
il y a la question des armateurs en
Grèce dont il va falloir s'occuper de
manière très sérieuse et puis et puis
d'une manière générale réinvestir dans
les secteurs porteurs qui vont recréer
de l'emploi et qui vont relancer une
dynamique et notamment tous les secteurs
écolos bien sûr suivez mon regard même
si pour l'instant tipras sur l'écologie
n'est pas très allant donc pour
l'instant mais en tout cas il inspire
certains dont Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui en
a profité pour tenter un rapprochement
avec Cécile Duflot et les vers écouter
ce que pensent certains de vos collègues
à l'assemblée de cette initiative
avec lui oui c'est son choix là c'est
sûr que les écologistes n'ont pas
vocation à se rallier ou à se diluer
dans le Front de gauche le rassemblement
de la gauche et les écologistes ne peut
pas exclure le Parti socialiste comme le
souhaiterait Monsieur Mélenchon où il ne
peut pas sélectionner les bons et les
mauvaises socialistes les positions de
Cécile Duflot si elles vont dans le sens
de remettre en cause la politique
gouvernante si elle considère que les
choix du gouvernement sont des choix
libéraux si elle le dit si elle le porte
tant mieux et on voit bien qu'il y a des
convergences très fortes entre les Verts
les écolos et entre les députés du Front
de gauche alors est-ce que pour vous
barbara Pompili une alliance entre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Cécile Duflot entre
les Verts et les rouges seraient contre
nature ou pas d'abord nous on est pour
faire des rassemblements mais les
rassemblements c'est c'est avec tout le
monde on doit pas choisir un projet
moi je n'aime pas quand j'entends dire
que on doit se rassembler avec les uns
mais on doit virer les autres il faut se
rassembler sur un projet commun et nous
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire après on
a beaucoup exploité cette histoire du
meeting je rappelle que le meeting
n'était pas un meeting
Jean-Luc Mélenchon jusqu'au Parti
communiste c'était un meeting de soutien
à séries le parti écologiste soutient
Syriza dans sa démarche donc c'était ça
le message après d'autres ont voulu y
voir beaucoup de choses même certains
chez nous ont voulu y voir beaucoup de
choses simplement c'est du fond c'est du
flot à rappeler elle-même qu'elle était
là pour soutenir cyriza ou pas en 2017
c'est possible ça nouvelle donne
ici mais je vous assure vraiment moi je
crois que on se sent oui peut-être mais
on se fout revoir en parlant que de 2017
va être indexée sur ce qui va se passer
pendant deux ans et je n'en sais
strictement rien posé lui la question si
vous voulez avoir sa réponse moi ce qui
m'intéresse
dans notre groupe à l'Assemblée nous
parlons des propositions de loi que nous
déposons par exemple les quatre
propositions de loi dont nous avons
parlé hier et chacun montre le travail
des écolos chacun sa liberté de parole
tout en respectant le travail collectif
c'est à dire que le le parti c'est le
parti le groupe prend des positions et
les positions du groupe sont les
positions du groupe après si des
personnes sont ça c'est la liberté chez
nous si certains si certains se sent un
peu en désaccord avec une position du
groupe ils peuvent le dire mais tout en
expliquant ce qu'est la position tout ça
et on va parler maintenant peut-être de
la position de quelle est la position de
votre groupe sur un le sujet du jour
mardi les 12 travaux d'Hercule c'est à
dire la loi Macron dans les muscles
la loi Macron qui poursuit son chemin
dans l'hémicycle dans la douleur
l'examen de ce texte pour déverrouiller
l'économie française et rythmée par
beaucoup de passes d'armes entre
majorité opposition et par des
interruptions de ses hanches chacun à sa
position elle n'est pas forcément claire
alors qui va voter quoi le point avec
Elsa un ministre de l'économie qui
entend défendre sa loi pendant les 50
heures de temps programmé une loi censée
incarner la volonté de réforme du
gouvernement mais que l'opposition
qualifie d'insuffisante tout ceci
témoigne d'une bonne volonté que je ne
veux pas persifler mais cela n'est pas à
la hauteur de la situation sur le
travail du dimanche un des points durs
les critiques viennent de la droite mais
aussi de l'extrême gauche contrairement
à ce que vous affirmez ce n'est donc
plus une exception plus de zones seront
concernées rarement il est vrai
nous n'aurions vu un test qui privilégie
de manière aussi cynique systématique
l'entreprise sur le salarié la
consommation sur la vie familiale alors
Emmanuel Macron se veut pragmatique
c'est une liberté pour protéger là où
cela a du sens les commerces de
centre-ville pour éviter que là où vous
n'êtes ouverte que 5 dimanche quand la
zone commerciale à côté a eu droit à 52
vous pouvez si ça a du sens pour vous
passer à 12 dimanche si ça n'en a pas
n'ouvrez que de dimanche par an liberté
offerte aux élus un discours qui séduit
une petite partie de l'UMP comme Hervé
Mariton qui n'hésite pas à tacler son
propre camp notre président de groupe
nous le rappelle à juste titre
au fond
le rôle de l'opposition c'est de
s'opposer
et je m'accorde bien à cela
jusqu'où
pas au point de s'empêcher d'agir demain
pas au point de se contredire sur ce
qu'on a pu faire penser proposer hier
des soutiens inattendus mais
suffiront-ils à équilibrer les doutes de
la majorité les frondeurs promettent de
faire entendre leur voix lors des débats
le ministre a beaucoup communiqué sur le
fait que la commission spéciale qui
s'était réunie la semaine dernière avait
permis d'appurer les difficultés mais il
en reste quand même suffisamment pour
que les députés socialistes comme nous
ressentent le besoin de poursuivre la
discussion et le combat dans l'hémicycle
il reste deux semaines au ministre de
l'économie pour convaincre le vote pas
prévu le 10 février
10 février pour le vote sur ce texte qui
risque d'être donc voté avec des voix de
droite est-ce que ça vous agace quelle
est la position des verres aujourd'hui
sur le fait que des voix de droite
puissent ajouter au texte je considère
que j'ai toujours pensé que s'opposer
pour s'opposer de manière stérile
n'avait pas de sens et que quand un
texte était bon même si on était dans
l'opposition on pouvait le voter ça
c'est ça c'est un point sur la loi
Macron sur la loi Macron nous nous
considérons aujourd'hui que le texte ne
répond pas aux attentes qu'on pourrait
avoir en commission malgré tout le
travail qui a été fait nos députés se
sont exprimés contre
elle s'est exprimée sur la partie
logement elle s'est exprimée sur la
partie logement sur laquelle elle a une
certaine légitimité il me semble à
s'exprimer puisque il y a des mesures
effectivement dans la loi Macron qui
remettent en cause la loi allure sur
laquelle elle a travaillé il me semble
légitime qu'elle sent qu'elle s'en est
neuve au minimum après sur les sur les
autres mesures de la loi Macron nous on
considère qu'une bonne loi aujourd'hui
pour remettre l'économie en marche est
une loi qui doit s'appuyer sur les trois
piliers du développement durable qui
sont l'économie l'environnement et le
social et il faut combiner tout cela
pour qu'on réussisse à avoir une loi qui
est du sens aujourd'hui avec les enjeux
de nous avons
les trois pays ou est-ce qu'il y a non
non malheureusement sur la question du
travail du dimanche aujourd'hui il nous
manque c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
un certain nombre de garanties alors on
nous dit et nous avons entendu que
aujourd'hui il y a à chaque fois des il
devra y avoir des accords pour que on
puisse travailler un certain nombre de
dimanches mais ces accords pour
l'instant on n'en sait pas plus on ne
sait pas à quel niveau ils sont ce qui
peut être très différent si c'est un
accord de branche un accord d'entreprise
etc et puis c'est vraiment une réflexion
globale sur notre société est-ce qu'on
veut que il n'y ait plus de moments un
peu sanctuarisés c'est une vraie
question il y a plein et bien et bien
justement sur les autres sur les autres
sujets
c'est important
national
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous faites
votez pour voter contre les tags
sur le sur cette loi on en a on en a
travaillé on en a travaillé 9 en séance
donc il en reste presque 200 encore à
étudier un peu d'espace c'est quand même
aussi une loi qui veut relancer l'emploi
qui veut déverrouiller l'économie
française on voit que le taux de chômage
atteint des nouveaux records bien sûr
les pas si mauvaises finalement nous
voulons absolument relancer l'emploi
mais nous sommes absolument convaincus
que l'emploi est n'est pas du tout
empêché par l'écologie bien au contraire
nous considérons que l'écologie est un
vecteur de relance de l'emploi dans des
secteurs de l'énergie du bâtiment les
artisans ont besoin de travail et là
pour justement rénover les les
appartements ou les maisons pour les
mieux les isoler ça donne de l'emploi et
puis je vous parle pas des transports ou
les infrastructures où il y a un énorme
travail à faire mais sur l'environnement
justement le problème de cette loi
essentiellement aussi c'est que elle
fait passer par ordonnance énormément de
points très importants de modifications
très importantes de notre législation ça
c'est antidémocratique on confie ce
qu'elle faisait des arguments sont
droits de travailler et les ordonnances
notamment passent sur le droit de
l'environnement on remet on revoit une
grosse partie du code de l'environnement
sans que nous puissions en débattre et
nous n'avons à cette heure-ci aucune
garantie que la protection de
l'environnement sera préservée ce qui
pose quand même de gros problèmes pour
nous écologistes si vous voyez là des
problèmes sur l'écologie et notamment
sur ce travail en ordonnance qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez réagir vous on a déposé des un
certain nombre d'amendements
il y en a qui ont déjà été adoptés ne
soyons pas complètement négatifs et nous
on est vraiment dans une démarche de
travail constructif je sais c'est pour
ça que vous parlez de
si vraiment nous amendements étaient
adoptés et que la loi permettait de nous
rassurer sur un certain nombre de points
on pourrait faire évoluer notre vote
mais aujourd'hui il est vrai que là je
ne vois pas comment pourrait laver on va
parler de votre réponse
on va passer sur un autre volet de
l'actualité des dizaines d'heures en
séance après aussi pour ça que si ça ne
sert à rien et si on va tout de suite
voter contre moi je travaille aussi
votre position il y a d'autres travail
qui a eu cette semaine au Sénat qui a
été votée c'est ce qu'on appelle la loi
note sur la réforme du territoire et
notamment la droite a un petit peu
détricotée ce que le gouvernement est
mis en place on voit ça avec Faustine sa
jeunesse
on attendait un grand champ
barbecion territorial de la République
devait redistribuer les compétences
qu'en est-il concernant les régions le
gouvernement et les sénateurs disent oui
à des compétences élargies développement
économique innovation ou encore
coordination des acteurs de l'emploi et
de la formation professionnelle mais pas
question de leur laisser les collèges ni
les transports scolaires ou la voirie
départementale il reste au département
certains y compris dans la majorité au
Sénat dénonce une occasion ratée je
pense qu'ils ont tort de sarque-booter
surtout
parce que ça donne une image au fond
qui n'est pas
positive et qui n'est pas suffisamment
qui montre pas suffisamment qu'ils ont
besoin de la réforme les départements
gardent donc collège transport scolaire
voirie et se voit conforter dans leur
rôle de garant des solidarités sociales
et territoriales avec le RSA par exemple
enfin pas touche non plus aux
intercommunalités le gouvernement
voulait augmenter leur seuil minimal à
20000 habitants hors de question pour
les sénateurs de la majorité ce seuil
restera à 5000 au grand dames du
gouvernement et de l'opposition ici au
Sénat une touche à rien est une très
mauvaise solution parce qu'on sait que
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens attendent
des services attendent des collectivités
qui soient dynamiques et que des petites
intercommunalités n'ont pas les moyens
ni d'offrir les services ni d'assurer le
développement de leur territoire le
Sénat adopter le texte mardi à l'issue
d'un vol solennel la commission des lois
de l'Assemblée nationale comment ces
auditions dès la semaine prochaine
j'aurais qu'une seule question rien ne
change au Sénat les départements sont
confortés quel sera votre position à
l'Assemblée quand le texte va arriver
c'est à dire dans d'ici peu de temps
notre position à l'Assemblée si
l'organisation de notre territoire n'est
pas plus clair n'est pas plus simple et
compréhensible pour les gens il n'est
pas plus efficace je ne vois pas
l'intérêt de cette réforme donc il va
falloir que on travaille pour clarifier
tout cela le départ c'était ne jamais
oublier c'était simplifier millefeuille
territoriales qui est moins de niveau et
que les citoyens s'y retrouvent et c'est
trois objectifs là qu'on doit absolument
remplir s'ils sont pas remplis les
conséquences politiques et pas logique
écoutez moi le seul redécoupage que j'ai
vu pour l'instant c'est celui des
régions qui ont été en fait fusionnés
mais nous nous considérions qu'il
fallait redonner du pouvoir aux régions
et aux intercommunalités aujourd'hui
avec des plus grandes régions ça redonne
du poids au département alors que les
départements devaient sortir du genre
bref tout est à nouveau sur la table
mais je n'ai pas le sentiment que cette
réforme sera la grande réforme que nous
ayons ou que nous avions souhaité mais
ça je compris moi passer au décryptage
de lecture avec notre partenaire du
Figaro c'est la loupe du scan
bonjour Jim Jara c'est rédacteur au chef
du scan politique du Figaro va commencer
l'actualité avec notamment on va appeler
ça les parlementaires et leurs
indemnités tout à fait bonjour barbara
Pompili alors je voulais vous parler de
votre indemnité de frais de mandat ou
IRFM alors qu'est-ce que c'est c'est une
enveloppe de 5300 euros net non
imposable qui est versé chaque mois au
député pour couvrir leurs frais
professionnels on en a parlé cette
semaine pourquoi parce que plusieurs
sites d'infos ont révélé que plusieurs
élus utilisaient cette enveloppe IRFM
pour à des centres privés pour financer
des biens immobiliers par exemple vous
barbara Pompili comment vous utilisez
cette enveloppe
pour ce pourquoi elle est faite
c'est-à-dire pour mes frais de mandat
donc je l'utilise pour la location de ma
permanence je l'utilise pour tous les
frais liés à l'édition d'un bulletin du
député qui est distribué
aux personnes je l'utilise pour mes
déplacements je l'utilise aussi pour des
frais pour acheter des vestes ou des
choses comme ça
ou des campagnes non non mais ce système
de l'IRFM est un système qui en soit est
profondément pernicieux parce que il n'y
a aucun contrôle sur ce qui est fait
l'IRFM et il ne nous était pas jusqu'à
présent maintenant il y a un gros
travail du déontologue qui est en train
d'être fait il ne nous était pas donné
de véritable indication sur ce qui
pouvait être fait et surtout sur ce qui
ne pouvait savoir changer avec le temps
et donc beaucoup ont joué sur le flou
pour faire un peu
tentés justement pour essayer de
d'imposer des garde-fous pourquoi ça n'a
jamais abouti pourquoi après tant
d'années on est toujours sur une opacité
complète de l'utilisation des des de la
de l'argent des parlementaires
parce que je crois qu'il y a d'abord des
conservatismes nous quand on a voulu
mettre un peu de transparence parce
qu'on a été un peu moteur sur ces
histoires de transparence on a toujours
eu beaucoup d'oppositions parce que
justement des vieilles habitudes font
que certains n'ont pas trop envie qu'on
sache ce qui s'est passé mais maintenant
il faut vraiment avancer ce besoin de
transparence encore plus aujourd'hui
dans la situation de notre démocratie et
nécessaire donc il faut que on sache
précisément pourquoi on peut utiliser
l'URSS pourquoi on ne peut pas
l'utiliser et qu'il y ait des
possibilités de contrôle par le
déontologue par exemple on parle de la
polémique de la semaine c'est le prix
remis par les journalistes du
Trombinoscope au maire d'énains Beaumont
ça fait polémique c'était mardi soir à
l'Hôtel De La c'est la résidence du
président de l'Assemblée nationale donc
les les journalistes de l'association du
trouble score on décide de remettre ce
prix à Steve Briois le maire frontiste
d'Hénin-Beaumont on voit ce prix à
l'écran Claude Bartolone le président de
de l'assemblée a décidé de boycotter
cette cérémonie est-ce qu'il a eu raison
selon vous
et son droit d'abord c'était son droit
les choix qui ont été faits sont des
choix que les journalistes ont le droit
de faire après la question c'est quel
message on fait passer par là il me
semble que le prix qui a été donné à
Steve Briois c'était le prix sur le
travail d'un élu
bon faire comme si le Front national
était un parti comme les autres faire
comme si le Front national justement
parce que c'est la presse qui délivre ce
ce
prix faire comme si le Front national
n'avait pas de problème avec la presse
moi un parti qui interdit des
représentants de la presse dans certains
de ces meetings je serai journaliste ça
me poserait un problème après sur
l'action
d'abord ça fait très peu de temps qu'il
est élu et ensuite sur sur l'action moi
j'aurais préféré
que l'on mette en valeur par exemple
Eric Piol le maire de Grenoble qui a mis
en place un système complètement
novateur avec la société civile on sait
que le FN passe ses journées à dénoncé
le système politique au médiatique
est-ce que le meilleur moyen de limiter
les sortes de ce parti c'est pas aussi
de le faire rentrer dans ce fameux
système ah bah ça c'est sûr que
de c'est effectivement le seul point un
peu connaissance c'est que là il pourra
plus dire que il n'est plus dans ce
fameux système parce que là il y est
rentré même si j'ai entendu apparemment
des menaces ou des presque menaces de
Marion Maréchal-Le Pen à l'égard d'un de
vos collègues que j'ai trouvé fortement
déplacés
il y a eu deux invités politiques en
l'occurrence Julien Dray qui est donc
très proche de François Hollande et
Christian Estrosi ils ont tous les deux
étaient incapables de citer le nom du
ministre de la ville on regarde la
réponse de Christian Estrosi
hier matin à votre place Julien Dray je
lui ai demandé qui était le ministre de
la ville il a un peu séché vous savez
vous en pas trop
pas trop
alors barbara Pompili vous me voyez
venir vous le connaissez vous le nom du
ministre de la Ville oui c'est Monsieur
kaner c'est un Lillois
évidemment la semaine prochaine et on
poursuit avec une législative partielle
très suivie dans le Doubs
Manuel Valls a fait le déplacement pour
soutenir le candidat socialiste de la
quatrième circonscription du Doux
l'intervention du Premier ministre a été
perturbé par une panne d'électricité
mais il a quand même pu lancer son appel
écouter
que nous soyons fiers de cette gauche
qui ne cède pas comme d'autres peuvent
le faire souvent
à la facilité la gauche celle qui est là
et forte pas quand il s'adresse à une
pas quand elle se divise pas quand elle
n'a pas le sens des responsabilités dans
un moment difficile
les Français ont conduit les règles
du pouvoir le destin de la nation à fond
sur l'or pourquoi il nous fait parce que
précisément c'était difficile
mais dans ces moments-là ceux qui
gouvernent doivent assumer le
responsabilité
c'est une élection qui s'annonce
difficile pour le Parti socialiste
quelle est la toux du PS pour l'emporter
Manuel Valls
écoutez en tout cas ils ont raison de
s'appuyer sur le Premier ministre
puisque le Premier ministre semble avoir
le vent en poupe ces temps-ci maintenant
ce que je trouve ce que je trouve
dommage c'est que si quand il y a un
enjeu comme celui-là est notamment avec
le Front National qui est en position de
force dans cette circonscription que le
PS n'est pas été capable de rassembler
sa majorité c'est ce que je reproche au
PS en ce moment si vous vous avez un
candidat qui part seul ah bah écoutez
bien sûr que on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas dire que ceux qui font la division
sont toujours les plus petits au bout
d'un moment quand on veut rassembler
autour de soi il faut aussi donner aux
autres l'envie de se rassembler et leur
proposer des des manières de travailler
ensemble qui sont satisfaisantes
nationales dans le dos l'unité nationale
n'a jamais voulu dire la mort du débat
démocratique vous voyez vous cela au
contraire au contraire depuis le 11
janvier ce qu'on voit c'est une grande
aspiration non seulement à la liberté
mais aussi à la préservation de notre
démocratie la préservation de notre
démocratie ce n'est pas la mort du débat
vous parliez de Manuel Valls RTL c'est
ça même deux sondage qui tient deux
enseignements le premier qui est
important c'est que Marine Le Pen reste
en tête au premier tour pas loin de 30
33% des voix quel que soit le candidat
sauf si manuel en tout cas premier tour
et le seul qui pourrait faire gagner le
camp de la gauche c'est Manuel Valls
même devant François Hollande François
Hollande arriverait même pas au deuxième
tour c'est le Sauveur
c'est normal que vous fassiez non non
non c'est normal que vous fassiez des
sondages mais un sondage c'est voilà
c'est une photo à un moment donné que
que
se révèle sous bonne vague oui mais
justement c'est intéressant vous parliez
tout à l'heure on reparler des
stratégies pour 2017 etc etc moi ce que
je constate c'est que aujourd'hui si on
veut envisager que la gauche puisse être
en position de l'emporter en 2017 il y a
deux ans de travail et du travail lourd
à faire et c'est ces deux ans de travail
de travail pour la majorité parce que
toute la majorité a intérêt à ce que ce
ne soit ni la droite ni Front National
qui passe en attendant c'est quand même
Manuel Valls qui incarne au vu de ses
sondages le Front républicain à lui seul
oui il incarne là maintenant et c'est le
premier ministre bon voilà je moi je
sais que les sondages ça évolue beaucoup
dans un sens dans un autre donc je n'ai
pas trop envie de me coller à ça pour
choisir la stratégie que je vais choisir
et par ailleurs Marine Le Pen qui en
tête des intentions de votre quoi qu'il
arrive et on voit qu'il y a pas eu
forcément l'effet des manifestations
auxquelles elle n'a pas participé au 11
janvier
le fait que le Front national malgré ce
qui s'est passé le début janvier
continue de progresser et continuent à
s'implanter durablement en tête des
partis politiques français c'est sur ça
qu'on doit travailler et elle se nourrit
évidemment de notre crise économique du
manque de perspective d'emploi et ça
malheureusement la grande mobilisation
du 11 janvier n'y a rien changé je suis
suffisamment inquiète pour considérer
que là maintenant il faut vraiment
travailler tous ensemble pour relever
notre pays l'intérêt général c'est que
bien sûr toute la gauche doit réussir à
s'unir pour travailler pour la gauche
les plus frondeurs bien sûr bien sûr on
doit travailler tous ensemble pour
l'intérêt général c'est un sujet on
verra être suffisamment important si
vous êtes entendu en tout cas à
l'Assemblée au Sénat on a travaillé sur
un sujet qui préoccupe beaucoup le
gouvernement la France comment lutter
contre le jihad 2.0 c'est à dire le
recrutement par Internet de volontaire
au départ pour la Syrie et l'Irak la
question est posée notamment au Sénat
avec une table ronde tour d'horizo des
solutions envisagées avec Louis civil
c'est un petit manuel un site du
ministère de l'Intérieur reprend les
mêmes armes que les cybergihadistes et
retrace le processus de radicalisation
qui passe d'abord par les réseaux
sociaux
objectifs dénaturer la propagande
djihadiste une communication choc depuis
les attentats le gouvernement met les
bouchées doubles pour lutter contre le
cyber terrorisme une plateforme a été
mise en place pour signaler des contenus
illicites sur la toile entre 2013 et
2014 il y aurait eu trois fois plus de
discours djihadistes sur Internet nous
signalons un certain nombre de
comportements sur les réseaux sociaux la
réactivité de Facebook est
adapté à la législation américaine et
n'est pas systématiquement adossé à la
nôtre il y a des choses que nous
considérons comme illicite et qui
ressortent pour les Américains du
Premier Amendement par exemple et qui
moderne finalement leur approche de
notre demande c'est bien une guerre sur
la toile qui est engagée le Premier
ministre parle de cyberpatrouille dans
la gendarmerie notamment avec un renfort
de 60 personnes pour lutter contre le
terrorisme sur Internet une commission
au Sénat cherche à voir comment
accélérer le processus de signalisation
dans le collimateur les hébergeurs de
sites sommet d'agir plus comportement
certains défendent la liberté
d'expression on va tenter de transformer
des acteurs d'Internet que ce soit
Twitter Facebook ou Google en une espèce
de police privée du cybergyad et on voit
fuser les réactions de la part du
Premier ministre et du président de la
République qui vont dans ce sens ont
tout 60 millions d'euros vont être
spécifiquement consacrés à la prévention
de la radicalisation selon Manuel Valls
3000 personnes seraient à surveiller
est-ce que vous pensez dit que sans
l'accord des géants américains Facebook
Twitter Google la France peut vraiment
gagner la bataille la lutte contre le
djihad 2.0 c'est un sujet extrêmement
complexe et moi je ne m'aventurerai pas
à donner une solution que il faille
qu'on sache ce qui se passe et donc le
renseignement fasse son travail aussi au
niveau d'internet
on a des moyens on a des moyens de
travailler qu'il faille adapter la loi
peut-être mais ce que je vois surtout
c'est que on efface un phénomène
d'embrigadement sectaire de type
sectaire ce sont des jeunes qui ou des
moins jeunes d'ailleurs qui sont dans
une telle perte de repères qui partent
dans cet engrenage là alors ça c'est un
vecteur qui existe mais en même temps
mais en même temps je considère s'il n'y
avait pas des personnes fragiles qui
étaient capables de tomber là dedans on
en arriverait pas là donc j'ai plutôt
l'impression que là on se focalise
là-dessus sans trop penser aux origines
du mal et les origines du mal
ça vient de la perte de repère ça vient
d'un manque de perspective de personnes
qui ne se sentent pas à leur place ou
qui sont très fragiles c'est là dessus à
mon avis qu'on a intérêt à travailler
beaucoup quel outil quel moyen l'école
l'école évidemment lui demander
énormément de choses à l'école mais il
est vrai trop on lui demande beaucoup
maintenant on sait que là on a un vrai
travail de renouveau des pédagogies pour
qu'il n'y ait plus de personnes qui
soient exclu comme elles le sont trop
aujourd'hui on a quand même un quart des
élèves qui partent du système scolaire
sont diplôme et c'est souvent dans ces
personnes là qui n'ont pas de
perspective que on peut trouver un
terreau fertile donc qui est des élèves
qui se sentent plus intégrés dans un
collectif dans un groupe qui ne se
sentent pas abandonné c'est très
important après il y a un gros travail à
faire dans les quartiers avec les
parents les familles qui aujourd'hui
sont à la porte de l'école mais tout ce
travail là il est déjà entamé mais c'est
un travail de très long terme la
baguette magique ça n'existe pas sur ces
sujets là il faut accepter au moins une
génération pour pouvoir avoir les
résultats peut-être une génération bon
c'est beaucoup mais c'est du long terme
c'est évident juste moi partez de la
semaine dernière et vous avez choqué ou
pas ça a beaucoup fait
j'ai considéré que c'était si si moi
j'ai répondu j'ai considéré que c'était
inapproprié parce que
c'est un c'est un mot qui a un sans
historique précis après ce qu'il a voulu
dire je suis d'accord avec lui sur ce
qu'il a voulu dire j'aurais pas employé
ce mot-là mais franchement pour moi ça
ça ne méritait pas toute la polémique
que ça a fait alors on va passer au
jeudi un peu de rufifier entre
l'Assemblée et le Sénat
et oui du rififi Claude bartholone c'est
prononcé pour la suppression du Sénat
alors vous imaginez bien entendu la
réaction des sénateurs et du président
du sénager hermarché qui a cessé toute
discussion avec son homologue journée de
crise suivie par Samir déchire
il aurait suffi d'une phrase pour
déclencher la polémique des propos tenus
ce matin par Claude bartholon à plante à
la suppression du Sénat moi je suis pour
la fin du Bic amerisme sous cette forme
en tant que Sénat sous la forme telle
que l'on la connaît aujourd'hui oui la
réaction du Sénat ne se fera pas
attendre après un entretien de 12
minutes avec Claude Bartolone Gérard
Larcher publie un communiqué sanglant
constatant le profond désaccord sur leur
conception institutionnelle le président
du Sénat a considéré que le travail en
commun avec le président de l'Assemblée
nationale n'était plus possible la
rupture semble consommer sur son compte
Twitter Gérard Larcher annonce qu'il met
fin à la mission commune aux deux
assemblées sur les valeurs républicaines
puis en début d'après-midi le président
du Sénat convoque les présidents des
groupes politiques après 15 minutes de
concertation il rejoignent l'hémicycle
et enchaîne les interventions pour une
condamnation unanime j'ai été
particulièrement choquée
par les propos du président Barcelone le
président de l'Assemblée nationale
Claude barthelon a commis une faute nous
défendons le Sénat parce que nous sommes
profondément attachés au travail que
nous y faisons tous des propos dont mal
vécu qu'on avril dernier dans un sénat
encore majoritairement à gauche Claude
bartholan se faisait lardons défenseur
du bicamérisme depuis le Directoire
quelle que soit la nature du régime
considéré le bicamérisme a le plus
souvent
caractérisée sous des avatars divers le
système institutionnel français il fait
ainsi parti de notre ADN démocratique
mais en octobre dernier le président de
l'Assemblée change son fusil d'épaule
dans son livre je ne me tairai plus il
évoque une nécessaire suppression du
Sénat en réalitérant sa proposition ce
matin Claude bartholone a réussi à
mettre d'accord tous les sénateurs
contre lui
suppression du Sénat ou pas
j'ai l'impression que c'est une tempête
dans un verre d'eau parce que
ça concerne le parle
ment qu'on ait
sur nos institutions c'est très
important nous écologistes ça fait très
longtemps que nous proposons une réforme
profonde du Sénat qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a plus de dix amérisme mais
qui dit simplement que aujourd'hui la
manière ne sait la Sénat est élu n'est
peut-être pas complètement satisfaisante
sénatisfait un sénat qui serait
représentant des régions par exemple
pourrait dans une nouvelle dans une dans
une réforme institutionnelle plus
globale ça pourrait être intéressant
du Sénat mais sous sa forme actuelle oui
c'est pas je veux pas supprimer le Sénat
je veux qu'il soit réformé en profondeur
pour qu'il corresponde démocratiquement
à quelque chose de plus visible pour les
citoyens aujourd'hui un citoyen ne sait
même pas comment un sénateur est élu et
très éloigné du sénateur il ne sait pas
à quoi il sert vraiment et donc même
pour le Sénat en lui-même il y aurait
intérêt à revoir son mode d'élection et
son mode de fond et vous dites pas tout
de suite c'était pas le moment pour vous
c'était pas le moment de lancer ce débat
comme l'a fait Claude Bartolone c'était
un problème de c'est jamais le moment et
puis
de Bartolone a dit ça dans son livre qui
est sorti il y a déjà plusieurs mois ça
déclenche quand même une sorte de guerre
froide là c'est dommage c'est dommage
mais est-ce que cette guerre froide est
vraiment basée sur du fond politique ou
est-ce que c'est encore un petit peu de
la polémique politique on doit pouvoir
discuter de tout
le sentiment parce que je ne vois pas en
quoi le fait qu'il y ait une réflexion
sur le Sénat
empêche le président de l'anglais
national et le président du Sénat de
travailler ensemble sur les suites sur
les suites du 7 janvier qui n'a
strictement rien à voir le Sénat on peut
avoir une réflexion sur son mode de
fonctionnement son mode d'élection mais
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui il fonctionne
et donc il faut faire avec nous nous
sommes pour une réforme profonde des
institutions pour le passage à une
sixième république et pourtant nous
travaillons dans le cadre de la 5e
République je crois vraiment que les
citoyens méritent que le débat soit un
petit peu plus élevé que ça le travail
législatif entre vous là dans les
prochaines semaines vous imaginez que ça
peut poser problème problème
écoutez je ne vois pas les navettes
parlementaires continuent mais en même
temps
sur le travail législatif en clair sur
le travail législatif a priori non après
il y avait une mission parlementaire sur
les suites du 7 janvier c'est quand même
dommage qu'on ne puisse pas travailler
sur un sujet aussi grave tous ensemble
ce sont des quasiment les plus hauts
personnages de l'État après le président
de la République et le premier ils
doivent aussi donner l'exemple ils
doivent aussi dominer l'exemple
exactement
the interview en français ça veut dire
l'interview qui tue alors vous avez
forcément entendu parler de ce film il a
surtout déclenché une polémique il est
devenu un cas unique dans l'histoire du
cinéma le film a été à l'origine d'une
gigantesque cyberattaque dont a été
victime la marque Sony regarde ça avec
Simon barbarie
le film est sorti mercredi en France
mais le feuilleton lui a commencé il y a
plusieurs semaines interview une comédie
potage qui tourne en ridicule le
dictateur nord-coréen Kim Jong-Un avait
pour le moins tendu les relations
diplomatiques entre Washington et puis
on young nous appelons la Corée du Nord
à la retenue et à ne pas lancer d'autres
actions menaçantes en novembre dernier
après avoir piraté les serveurs du
producteur du film Sony un groupe de
pirates informatiques baptisé les
gardiens de la paix montent d'un cran
dans ses intimidations et menace
d'attentats Sony ainsi que les
principales chaînes de cinéma du pays le
producteur avait alors préféré des
programmer la sortie américaine de the
interview au profit d'une diffusion sur
les plateformes de vidéos à la demande
au grand dam de Barack Obama je
comprends leurs inquiétudes cependant je
pense qu'ils ont fait une erreur
si l'implication de la Corée du Nord
dans ses attaques n'a pu être à ce jour
démontré Kim Jong-un n'en est pas moins
le sujet principal du scénario de The
interview de journalistes américains
sont mandatés par la CIA pour assassiner
le dictateur nord-coréen la caricature
est grossière souvent bébête mais même
lorsqu'elle est simpliste elle n'a
jamais tué personne
comme quoi encore la liberté
d'expression encore un petit peu de mal
elle est encore un petit peu de mal mais
ce qui est intéressant
un film en Corée du Nord pour expliquer
à quel point je ne sais pas tel
dirigeant est nul mais au moins la
liberté d'expression
mais répondre à une expression
artistique quelle qu'elle soit par la
violence par les attaques et par les
menaces c'est inacceptable et donc nous
devons lutter contre ça et même si ce
mauvais film doit être l'étendard de la
liberté d'expression et ce sera le mot
de la fin merci d'avoir été l'invité de
par le McDo et bonne semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale pour la loi Macron
et au cours du travail
et on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
même lieu même à bientôt ciao ciao